I'm not sure that formal storytelling is
exactly my metier but having a group of
people together like this is an
opportunity to tell a story which
puzzles me which is I think all good
stories should be puzzling and all myths
that are authentic and haven't been
rewritten for daytime television
maintain a kind of dreamlike surreal
quality and so I'd like to tell you a
story that I came upon a few months ago
and was delighted and I tell it to you
in the hope that you can perhaps help me
to understand it like all good stories
it doesn't really make a whole lot of
sense but I felt that there must be
something important in it because I it
was very easy to memorize
so that clued me to the fact that there
must be something in it and this story
comes from that ultimately pivotal
moment in Western civilization when the
last outpost of the goddess culture
which was Crete Minoan Crete fell and
was in the process of falling to the
pirate paternalist sub my Sania who with
advances in shipbuilding and an economic
base built on grain were beginning to
conquer the eastern Mediterranean and
one by one the last bastions of the of
the goddess religion were falling there
were also great earthquakes in the
eastern Mediterranean at this time which
also contributed to the disruption
of this civilization and the story that
I want to tell is a story that occurs
from the very oldest stratum of Greek
mythology this is not about the pantheon
of classical or even Doric Greece this
is an older story Mycenaean perhaps
older than that going back even to the
pastoralists coming out of Africa and
into the Fertile Crescent
it's a story set in the setting which is
probably familiar to most of you
although this story is only told in
palce Aeneas and alluded to in Herodotus
so it is not some story that even
classicists are too familiar with Robert
Graves in his 4-volume study of Greek
mythology gives it only passing
reference you may recall that King Minos
was the king of Crete and that he was
most famous for having built a labyrinth
in which to house the Minotaur and I'm
sure you know the story of the
traversing of the labyrinth and perhaps
you know that king - built the labyrinth
had need of it because his wife Queen
pasa Fey was an extremely sensuous and
experimentally minded young woman and
she became so interested in the sexual
habits of cattle that she had Icarus the
craftsman who was later to break out of
this scene on the Daedalus the guy who
was going to break out of this scene
later on the first flying machine she
had him fashioned for her an artificial
cow in which she hid
in order to have sexual union with the
Bulls in the royal flock and out of this
hanky-panky came the Minotaur and her
husband trying to cover up the series of
folk paws built the labyrinth installed
the Minotaur in the labyrinth and they
grew older and did less swinging and
began to settle down but then comes the
story I want to tell which is a few
years later the king and the Queen
apparently under quite normal conditions
conceived a child who was in due time
born and this child's name was Glaucus
Glaucus means blue gray and is to this
day a term preserved in taxonomy to
describe the blue gray color
typical of the peyote cactus and of the
bruising reaction of psilocybin
mushrooms and young Glaucus had the run
of the Royal Palace at Knossos and in
his sixth year he was exploring the
pantries of the palace and he discovered
a huge urn filled with honey and he took
the lid off the honey urn and was
reaching into it and fell into the honey
and was drown and died there and no one
knew what had become of the son of the
king and the Queen and there was tumult
as you can imagine in the court and
eventually queen paso fay in a state of
complete hysterical distraction went to
the great seer who advised the king's
general
and the Kings weather makers and she
said you must find our son and the seer
looked into the surface of oils poured
on water and burned hi sup leaves and he
said my magic is not sufficient to find
your son but I can lead you to one who
can find your son he said the person and
this is the part of the myth which is so
bizarre that you suspect that there must
be textual corruption or some kind of
misunderstanding because it's so weird
what follows the seer said the person
who can lead you to your son is that
person who can compose the most apt
simile on the tri-colored cow in your
herds what the tri-colored cow is what
kind of code language we're dealing with
can only be a matter of conjecture but
obviously the story at this point
is couched in a secret language which
conveyed meaning only to the initiative
the Queen commanded each citizen of the
Principality to appear before them and
compose a simile on the tri-colored cow
and there was a man there a minor
philosopher whose name was pauly a dose
and poly a dose you only have to have
spent two weeks in greek before you
transferred out to something a little
less horrifying to know that poly a dose
means many ideas so poly a dose the man
of many ideas went before the court and
he proposed a simile which according to
the account of Posse Gnaeus was
brilliant
he doesn't preserve it and hence it's
lost forever but whatever this simile
was it carried the day
and poly dose was actually a very humble
man a minor healer and magician and he
was puzzled that out of all the people
in the kingdom he had been chosen or he
had by fate been singled out as the one
who could solve this extremely racking
dilemma of the lost son for the king and
queen and he said to the king I have no
idea how to go about this how to find
your son and the Queen flew into a rage
and said he should be sealed into a
crypt with the body of our son and he
can come out when he comes out with our
son alive and so Polly a dose was seized
by force and notice now the motifs of
incarceration the dark night of the soul
the alchemical and closing of the primal
materia mean this is a rich rich myth so
Polly dose was seized by force and
placed into a crypt that was walled up
and the body of Glaucus was laid beside
him on a slab and as Polly [ __ ] sat
there be wailing his fate and rending
his clothes and calling out on the gods
to help him a snake entered the chamber
through some unseen tiny [ __ ] and the
snake approached the corpse of the child
lying in a dripping pool of presumably
dark attic honey on the polished stone
of the sarcophagi and and Polly dose
emerged out of his reverie and struck
out at the snake and killed it because
he was afraid it would violate the body
of the child and then seeing that the
snake was dead he went back to his
reverie and a few minutes late
second snake appeared and came to the
body of the first snake and reacted very
violently and before poly-a dose could
move to catch it quick as a wink it was
across the room and lost through a small
aperture in the floor and hours passed
and the depth of poly dose despair grew
and multiplied as he realized the
hopelessness of his situation and then
suddenly the second snake appeared again
and this time it was carrying in its
mouth a branch of a small herb and it
approached the corpse of its companion
and regurgitated the branch into the
mouth of the dead snake and the dead
snake was revived and the two snakes
went away struck dumb with amazement
and he called to his jailers and he
described this herb to them which was
well known to him for its use in other
medical matters and the herb was brought
to him and he chewed it up and he
regurgitated it into the mouth of the
corpse of young Glaucus and the child
was revived and Polly dose ass was saved
so he emerged and the king and the Queen
were jubilant and the court was jubilant
and the King said you can have anything
that you wish and go out and and Polly
Eidos who was actually a foreigner in
Crete said I want to journey to my
homeland I want to return to my homeland
and king- was on the brink of granting
the boon when Queen pacify intervened
and whispered in his ear and said you
cannot allow a magician of this power to
leave the kingdom we must somehow gain
his knowledge before we allow him to
depart from us and soaking - backtracked
and made a different deal and said you
can return to your homeland but first
you must teach all your magical arts to
my son Glaucus who you have resurrected
and so Polly a dose not liking it but
seeing the power of the King acceded to
the demand and over the course of many
years he taught all his shamanic and
magical arts to Glaucus and he schooled
him in all of the esoteric knowledge
that had made Polly a dose the unique
person able to recover the find the lost
child and finally he went to the king
and said I have taught all I know to
your son
I'll fulfill your promise and allow me
to leave your kingdom and so the king
was agreed and on the appointed day of
departure a royal retinue accomplished
accompanied Polly a dose to the key
where he was to grab the boat out to
Syracuse and they were embracing and the
last goodbyes were being said and
finally had only remained for Polly a
dose to make his departure to Glaucus
and he approached Glaucus and he said as
as my pupil as the one that I have
initiated I have one last request it is
that now at our farewell you spit into
my mouth and Glaucus thought it was a
bizarre request but he did as his master
bade him and Polly a dose boarded the
ship and they cast off and sailed away
and as the royal family was standing on
the key looking out to sea Glaucus
realized that all the magical
information that had been given to him
over the years had been contained in the
glob of spittle and that the master had
reclaimed his knowledge and sailed away
so that's the story of Glaucus and pali
he does funny part is that in the in the
original at first you said they wanted
to find they couldn't find the body and
then you said they they knew what the
body was and what we needed to revive
her well yeah I blew the story he he did
he Polly dose once chosen he dreamed and
saw the body in the honey but they were
so flipped out that their kid was dead
that the fact that he had found the body
and enough didn't buy him much slack yes
thank you for clarifying that
now the reason let me say a little bit
about it is a very interesting story I
found it while I was searching for proto
Hellenic myths related to mushrooms and
the there's something funny going on in
this story the fact that the blue-gray
child is preserved in the honey and then
is resurrected through the intercession
of another herb an herb known to the
snake and recall from the Genesis myth
that the snake is always the keeper of
the vegetable secrets it was the snake
who had the inner skinny on the flora
and fauna of Eden and so the snake comes
bearing information that then concerns
this herb of immortality and the ability
to resurrect the dead and it shows I
think the very late persistence of these
Paleolithic themes of shamanic power
carried and transmitted through through
plants if any of you have any other
insight into this why perhaps in the
afternoon what was may have been
eating a mushroom and gone into some
kind of coma state where he appeared
dead and then the task was to revive him
so they found an herb that restores
people who are apparently dead in the
Gilgamesh story there's also an herb of
immortality that the snake absconds with
and the snakes have always been the
especially credited with knowing the
secret of regeneration because of their
slopping their skin and all when you
know people in Mexico who go to Wat
learn places like that and collect a
mushroom the on the road old style way
of preserving the mushrooms was to put
them in honey and it turns into a
totally black mess it turns into the
alchemical primal materia it turns in to
the exudate of the grave but if you have
the courage to eat it it is then reborn
inside of you and honey the role of
honey as a pretty well any of you have
read lévi-strauss
honey and ashes and the raw and the
cooked know that you know this is a
symbol of semen of sunlight of sweetness
I mean it's a very rich kind of symbol
there are even it's reputed
hallucinogenic honey's in the Amazon
this is a whole unexplored area where
nobody has ever been able to walk into a
laboratory and slam down a quart jar of
hallucinogenic honey but there are
persistent reports filtering back from
wild-eyed travelers
[Music]
the metaphor of honey the Manas from
heaven yeah no I don't recommend
preserving mushrooms and honey if you
have a good freeze dryer and modern
refrigeration but otherwise you see the
honey draws the moisture out and it like
candies it and crystallizes it and makes
it impervious honey is highly antibiotic
nothing rots that is immersed yeah yes
mr. coffee is going to you had a story
to tell
no I tailored myself to your needs sir
and now I have nothing to say
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]